seit tagen haben wir fast überall in
deutschland richtig heißer temperaturen
ja und die bringen auch gewitter mit
sich gewitter bringen aber auch viele
schäden mit sich wie hier in steinfurt
dort hat ein blitz in ein fachwerkhaus
eingeschlagen und einen brand ausgelöst
rund 80 feuerwehrleute sind in der nacht
im einsatz um den brand unter kontrolle
zu bringen
das zweifamilienhaus ist vorerst nicht
mehr bewohnbar und genau über dieses
wetterphänomen möchte ich jetzt mit
dominik jung sprechen
hallo dominik wie kommt es denn
überhaupt zu gewittern und warum kommen
die immer erst abends also momentan ist
die bingo für gewitter wirklich sehr gut
ist nur sehr feucht warme luftmassen und
die feuchten luftmassen nicht steigen
nach oben und die kondensieren da haben
sie kühlen ab und dann bildet sich im
grunde wasserdampf das ist so ein
bisschen ähnlich wie man der dusche das
kind in der badewanne badet effekt
wasserdampf nach oben und dann bilden
sich die wolken die großen gewitter
türme ja und dann entstehen eben durch
elektrische ladung verteidigung
spannungen und dann kommt es eben zu
blitzen und dem typischen donner und
diese gewitter lage ist momentan eben
deswegen so heftig weil eben sehr viel
feuchtigkeit zur verfügung haben die im
grunde aufsteigen kann und es ist ein
bisschen wie den tropen aktuell viele
tropische gewitter möchte ich fast schon
sagen und merken es da draußen
es ist sehr schwül so drückend schwül
und natürlich kommt deswegen auch
nachmittags und abends am häufigsten vor
denn da ist einfach auch die luft am
wärmsten ist der höhepunkt der
temperatur des tages erreicht und die
warmen sehr warme luftmassen steigen
dann nach oben und kühlen sich ab und
dann bilden sich ebendiese
gewitterstürme und dann jetzt teilweise
auch und momentan haben wir auch sehr
willig luftströme und das heißt wenn
sich so eine gewitterzelle mal es
gebildet hat dann zieht die kaum von ort
und stelle und lädt quasi ihre fracht
immer wieder am gleichen ort ab und dann
besteht die gefahr von sturzfluten
gibt es denn auch unterschiedliche
plätze
ja es gibt also die bekanntesten kürze
sind natürlich so wollte näherte blitze
das sind ungefähr 20 prozent dann gibt
es 80 prozent das sind die meisten das
sind wolken wolken blitzen das heißt die
plätze erreichen überhaupt nicht die
erde für uns interessant sind natürlich
die blitze aus der wolke auf den
erdboden
denn die können uns natürlich auch
direkt am gefährlichsten werden wie
gesagt blitzschlag gefahr bei gewitter
natürlich aus dem wasser raus natürlich
nicht irgendwo im wald aufhalten
auch diese regel buchen sollst du suchen
eichen sollst du weichen die sollten wir
besser schnell vergessen denn ein baum
ist immer gefahr bei gewittern
der ragt ein sehr hoch aus der erde
heraus als aus dem umgebung raus und ist
natürlich schon ein erster punkt für den
blitz zum einschlagen gleiches gilt beim
baden im badesee oder im freibad der
eigene körper ist quasi die höchste
stelle in diesem wasser und deswegen
wird es dazu erst einschlagen und
deswegen sind gewitter auch ebenso
gefährlich vor allem spitze
die halter zum erdboden gelangen